and now to the equally exceptional women
who captivated us with emotionally
searing performances
here are the nominees for performance by
an actress in a supporting role
Angela Bassett Black Panther
[Applause]
the whale
Carrie Condon the Banshees of finishing
Jamie Lee Curtis everything everywhere
all at once
Stephanie shui everything everywhere all
at once
and the Oscar goes to
Jamie Lee
[Applause]
Jamie Lee Curtis made her big screen
debut in the horror classic Halloween 45
years later she was an executive
producer on the final installment
Halloween ends
thank you
[Applause]
stop I have 45 seconds and I promised
Janet Yang I wouldn't do it well because
I'm a good girl
I know it looks like I'm standing up
here by myself but I am not I am
hundreds of people I'm hundreds of
people I am Daniels Daniels Jonathan
leyline the entire crew my bay Michelle
key staff the entire art group of
artists who made this movie we just won
an Oscar to my dream team
my agent Rick kurtzman Alan wertheimer
Heidi Shafer Sean James Grace on Jane
Ross we just won an Oscar to my family
my beautiful husband Christopher Guest
our daughters
Annie and Ruby
my sister Kelly we just won an Oscar
to all of the people who have supported
the genre movies that I have made for
all these years the thousands and
hundreds of thousands of people we just
won an Oscar together
and my mother and my father were both
nominated for Oscars in different
categories
I just want an Oscar
[Applause]